okay so getting into really Action
Comics as part of the Superman reborn
aftermath this creates a pretty
interesting scenario for us and the
reason why is because of the fact that
what this does is basically give us like
this new and updated origin story of
Superman it basically kind of like wipes
away all the new 52 stuff which is
really interesting because the person
that we kind of have to ask here is is
this just Superman or is it everyone in
the DC Universe they just don't know it
yet maybe it's just kind of a phase
thing maybe it's just like the whole
idea that eventually will step in to the
notion of you know all the other
superheroes being rebooted we're not a
hundred percent sure at this point right
now it's just Superman now to provide a
little bit of context for people who are
just now stepping into the realm of DC
Comics and just kind of getting into all
these different superheroes and so on
when DC first launched the new 52 in
2011 as far as we knew there was just
the new 52 Superman and he was written
to be younger less-experienced and the
whole purpose of all of his stories in
the new 52 was to give us a context in
terms of how he becomes the more
experienced Superman how he eventually
becomes a Superman that we learned to no
one loved before the new 52 and so
because of that he was brash he was a
little more headstrong didn't quite have
the wisdom of his you know of how he was
before the new 52 but the issue was at
BAM just didn't really like him and they
just didn't really you know it didn't
really resonate with him for new
Superman readers it was about as close
as they got to the original gods that
they knew and loved and it was the only
Superman story that you were reading at
the time so because of that you were
able to get you know some some
interesting concepts but on the whole
were really the largely traditional
Superman fan base as large as they are
it just wasn't cutting it and so the
result was that sales started slipping
and so what DC did is they initiated a
story called the final days of Superman
and the final days of Superman were
basically just designed to set the stage
for the death of the new 52 Superman and
so what DC did during this time because
of the fact that the post DC you you
know going into the tail end of the new
52 because of the fact that it was
designed to set the stage for really DC
rebirth what DC did is they came back
and they would a story called Superman
Lois and Clark and this is when the
waters began to get a little bit murkier
the reason why was because of the fact
that what that story did is established
that were previously all we thought in
the new 52
that there was just the new 52 Superman
in reality the premium 52 Superman had
been there the entire time and we just
didn't know we for the longest time
believed that the pre new 52 Superman
appeared because of the events of
convergence we don't really need to go
super deep into that all it really did
is set the stage for DC to kind of bring
those characters in to kind of inject
them into the new 52 that was the most
logical assumption to make
you had convergence a led to be you know
ended it just kind of went in to its own
thing and that was really it now of
course because of the fact that this was
setting stage for the return of the pre
new 52 Superman as we knew him with the
final days of the new 52 Superman and
his passing the pre new 52 Superman took
its place and so that's how DC rebirth
went forward we effectively had the pre
new 52 Superman inside the new 52
universe is part of DC rebirth at least
that was the thought that was originally
given to us the cool thing about this
aftermath is that it shifts things up
because what we ended up finding out in
Superman reborn of course you'll find
that video here on my channel what we
ended up finding out is that when the
new 52 Superman died his energies were
just kind of compiled they were just
kind of out there and that was really it
I mean some of them went into Lois Lane
some of them went into Lana Lang but
essentially everything that made the new
52 Superman who he was was just kind of
floating out there during Superman
reborn these energies merged with the
pre new 52 Superman giving us the reborn
Superman and so what this story does is
explore the fallout from that and what
does it mean for the Superman landscape
and so the cool thing is that this
initially picks up with the a but the
kind of uneasiness you know that Clark
Kent's been feeling because remember
after the whole fact that he's been
reborn
you know his unease comes from something
that he can't quite put his finger on
and so what he ends up doing is
transitioning back to the fortress of
solitude and basically you only do all
these district crystals that essentially
give us his brand new origin and that's
the crazy thing here because what this
does is basically retcon the new 52 out
of continuity it's almost like it didn't
happen and so it was really kind of
crazy how this unfolds because again it
kind of brings us all back to the very
beginning it takes us to the early days
of Krypton or really to that to the the
eleventh hour of Krypton in the sense
that it is basically on its deathbed the
father of Superman jor-el basically went
to
catonian Council
look our planets going to be destroyed
you have to do something we have to make
fleets we have to evacuate the council
basically ignored him and that was it
notice here that we also get Kara zor-el
we get the cousin of of Clark Cantor I
guess a Superman in this equation so
what this is doing is rolling her back
in it's including her into all this
making her the cousin of Superman now
that was already established that's not
new
but again it really just kind of ties
into the idea that they're not leaving
her out she's still very much
intertwined with the history of Superman
now the reason why that matters is
because of the fact that after crisis on
Infinite Earths that whole one of the
whole aspects of that massive reboot was
to basically take Superman away from
being one of many Superman because
before crisis on Infinite Earths you had
Superman and he had Supergirl and then
he had Power Girl from a different
universe and he had Krypto the Superdog
and he had comet the superhorse and he
had that boat a super monkey and he had
all these super-powered beings all based
on Superman which was just a reflection
of the fact that he was so powerful and
so popular in the realm of DC Comics but
the problem was Superman was billed as
the last Son of Krypton the last
survivor of Krypton if he's the last
survivor of Krypton how do you explain
Supergirl how do you explain super horse
super cat super dog and how do you
explain all these different things and
so crisis on Infinite Earths went back
and said now Superman is the only
survivor of Krypton well Supergirl was
still extremely popular and so they
brought her back but they basically made
it like a robot kind of thing a weird
amalgamation of things for like a
different universe or something along
those lines this is DC basically saying
we are not repeating crisis on Infinite
Earths we are not going forward making
Superman the only survivor of Krypton
and there's no one else there's also
still Supergirl that's how we square the
circle of her character being alive in
DC rebirth now of course from here it
really just kind of goes on into the
whole notion of a fact that he was sent
away you know on a dying planet he
landed on earth Krypton was destroyed
and he was discovered by Jonathan and
Martha Kent now something else is also
important here is the character of Pete
Ross Pete Ross did not exist in the new
52 as far as I'm aware there's no
indication he was ever alive in the new
lady was one of the closest childhood
friends of Superman when he was on earth
in Smallville what this also does is
this basically brings in Geoff Johns
Superman's secret origin to the equation
and makes it official and so because
that it actually makes it really kind of
interesting because you know this
gives us a reason now to go back and
cover that and that's really one of the
kind of things that I was waiting for I
was looking for an opportune time
especially now since we're doing the new
52 Batman if that's successful and if
people are interested in that then we'll
do the new 52 Superman and will
basically cover the origin of Superman
before the new 52 as part of 'secret
origin or you might even just do it now
just for the sake of having it out there
since this story's there now and it's
grabbing all those things and bringing
them in but again a lot of this stuff
still stays pretty similar in the sense
that Lana Lang is still for the
childhood friend of Clark Kent innocence
that she's the one that basically taught
him how to use his powers once he had
them you know there's a whole day of the
tornado which we saw in Geoff Johns the
secret origin of Superman there's Lex
Luthor as a kid who discovered you know
kryptonite different things like that
all the origin aspects of Jeff Jones
Superman's secret origin are rolled into
this and all of it basically dead ends
into his travelling to Metropolis to
become Superman now one little thing
that I want to poke on here and we'll
actually find out here at the end of the
video what this is about but there's
someone who's basically speaking to
Superman in a very muffled and small
voice almost completely and totally
disabled it's actually so quiet
that the censors within the fortress of
solitude cannot pick up on what the
voices say you don't even know that it's
there Superman is the only one who can
hear it so again it's just really this
idea that whoever it is is talking knows
that really fall in a really small space
you know that gap between what Superman
can hear and what the voice detectors
and the fortress will pick up but from
this point going forward this is when we
start to get into the idea of
eliminating the entirety of the new 52
Superman history and replacing it with a
new one now the reason why this is
significant is because of the fact that
if you end up going out and you decide
that you want to start reading a new 52
Superman you know if you're new to the
Superman landscape if you're just
getting into DC rebirth and you want to
know all the lead-up that got to this if
you go back to the new fifties here
you're going to find two stories from
two comic books you're going to find
Superman and you're going to find Action
Comics you'll probably pick up Superman
first since that's the title that's the
more recognizable and then somewhere
along the line it'll say you know see
Action Comics
you'll go pick up Action Comics and
you'll be confused and the reason why is
because you'll see two stories taking
place at two different times when DC
first launched the new 52 they gave us
the Superman comics which took place in
the modern day of the new 52 when we got
action comics when we got new 52 Action
Comics
those took fly
five years in the past and basically
covered the older days of Superman now
that lasted for the first 18 issues and
issue number 19 going forward didn't
jump by five years and took place in the
modern day but the fact remains I wanted
to throw that out there for those of you
guys who are going to be new or going to
be getting into Superman and that kind
of a thing but the fact remains here
that again what this does is continue
going over his history within metropolis
operating under the guise of Clark Kent
being a reporter different things like
that but it also goes over the history
of the villains that he'd fought
Darkseid mister Mixel pillock imperiex
of course with this being from the 1990s
Superman the man of energy when he went
against Brainiac basically what it's
saying is that all the history of
Superman between crisis on Infinite
Earths and the new 52 reboot in 2011 all
that history is still intact
all that history still happened it's
still there not only that we also pick
up with the idea of him fighting
doomsday being beaten to death by
doomsday now something else would also
how also like you to notice too is that
it does cover the reign of the Superman
for those of you guys who don't know
when DC killed off Superman in 1992-93
or whatever was they launched a
year-long series of stories called the
reign of the Superman I at least I think
it was a year but basically it
introduced four new Superman you had
cyborg superman hank henshaw who was the
one for you no one responsible for
destroying Coast City and sitting Hal
Jordan down this insane path where he
eventually declared himself to be
parallax there was John Henry irons who
was a guy that had no powers that
basically fashioned himself a giant
Steel Superman suit and then there was
the Eradicator notice here there is no
metropolis kid there's no Conner Kent he
was one of the people who showed up he
was basically cloned to be Superman
called himself a metropolis kid or
something along those lines he's nowhere
to be seen here now whether he was left
out accidentally or whether he was left
out intentionally it's something that we
don't know we might find out later on
down the line but he's not here he's not
being included and this begs a litany of
questions is it because of the fact that
they're trying to keep the continuity
clean and so they simply don't want to
invoke any kind of answers or anything
like that about Superboy it's because DC
just doesn't want to treat him like he
exists anymore or is it because they're
going to do something like bring back
superboy-prime and they don't want to
super boys running around at the same
time we don't know the answer to that
question at this point it's really just
kind of guesswork and speculation but
again things like Superman marrying
Lois Lane revealing his identity to her
things like Superman having his parents
Jonathan and Martha Kent pass away those
things are all still intact now this is
where the whole idea begins to shift and
this is where the whole idea begins to
change
we're not exactly given this history
we're not exactly given this change the
implication here of this story right now
as it exists is that this is the history
of Superman in the new 52
that's what's so mind-blowing about this
because all this is all history of
Superman before the new 52 and so the
implication seems to be that this is the
history of Superman in the new 52 but
that begs the question what we're
rereading when the new 52 first started
what was all that stuff that was going
on but notice this there was not a lot
of grandiose storytelling I mean you
don't really think back to the new 52
run of Superman and recollect on things
like the Death of Superman against
doomsday you know imperiex invading
planet Earth and trying to eliminate
everybody Infinite Crisis Final Crisis
there were no stories like that
surrounding Superman in the new 52 so
Willy it'd be pretty easy to wipe that
away there's just not enough history
there to have made him very significant
and so again it's really just kind of a
wild scenario here but the fact remains
getting into the time in which Lois Lane
became pregnant this of course leads to
Superman basically moving away from
Metropolis setting up residents and the
fortress of solitude and then of course
calling Batman and calling Wonder Woman
to aside the Trinity more or less Lois
Lane giving birth to their child now
this is when the whole idea of Superman
Lois and Clark and the new 52 Superman
begin to blend together when Superman
Lois and Clark came out and was
basically the story that introduced the
pre new 52 Superman to the new 52
universe they took up residence in
Hamilton and the reason why that was
done the explanation that was given to
us at the time was because of the fact
that with the pre new 52 Superman in the
new 52 universe and the new 52 universe
already having its own Superman the free
new 52 Superman wanted to stay in the
background
he didn't want anybody to know he was
there at the same time he donned a black
uniform and he basically fought behind
the scenes he would save these small
little skirmishes are getting gauged in
these small little skirmishes he would
basically jump in and he would save like
a train that was going to go careening
off the tracks or something along those
lines things
that the new 52 Superman eater didn't
know about or didn't have the foresight
to see what's coming later on down the
road and so because of that what this
does is it tells us that's not the case
the reason why Superman and Lois Lane
moved to Hamilton was because of the
fact that they wanted to basically stay
off the radar again it was this idea
that you know essentially there was no
new disease Superman they're all just
one singular person this is a whole new
history here a whole new retcon being
introduced and so again what it did is
it allowed him to remain behind the
scenes but at the same time it also
allowed him to function as Superman
publicly so he could effectively be in
two places at once now the only other
explanation that I can think of that
makes sense to this the only other
explanation I can think of that that
could possibly make this make sense in
any form or fashion is that the memories
that Superman is picking up right now
are the memories of both the new 52 and
the pre new 52 Superman and a synthesis
almost like there's two sets of memories
in his own mind but that's not the
implication that's given here the
indication that's given here is that
there's one cohesive history not two
cohesive histories you know the idea is
that he's going through his own origin
story and his own origin story follows
that he both functioned as Superman and
the public eye and functioned as
Superman and the background keeping his
family safe that he basically put on a
disguise he put on a mask and tricked
the world into believing that there was
a legit Superman out there when in
reality he was basically keeping his
family safe and making a bunch of noise
over here so nobody would look over
there again a lot of questions are being
asked here a lot of information is being
done care to the point that there's
really going to have to be a lot of
explanation later on down the line but
if we go with the idea that this is true
if we go with the idea that Superman
reborn basically merged the new 52
Superman and the premium 52 Superman
into a sealer being and established a
whole new history then that begs the
question what's going on is it that he
basically woke up to what his real
history was that what we saw in the new
fridges he was an illusion that it
wasn't actually happening it wasn't real
that it was some mask or some fake
scenario that had been put on by
somebody like dr. Manhattan you know and
if that's the case then does that apply
to Batman does it apply to Wonder Woman
is it applied to Green Arrow - Hal
Jordan the Green Lantern's does it apply
to all of them is all the history we've
seen with them in the new 52 is that an
illusion is it think that there
Livius to their real history which is
basically everything before the new 52
that's kind of the question that's being
asked here and that's why all these
different stories that are going on in
DC a rebirth are so important is because
it basically hints at the idea that
there's a much bigger scenario going on
here because you got a thing out of this
way if somebody had the power let's
let's like for example if we kind of
follow this timeline of events all right
so let's say that we go back to
flashpoint all right Barry Allen wakes
up one day decides that it's a good idea
to keep his mother from dying
he travels into the past he saves her
life because he saves her life there was
no motivation for him to become the
flash at some key point along the line
and you know then the timeline it was
necessary for Barry to be the flash but
he wasn't there and the flashpoint
universe spun out as a result of that
the Amazons and the Atlanteans went to
war you know Aquaman Wonder Woman ended
up going to war with one another Bruce
Wayne was shot instead of Thomas and
Martha Wayne he died and so Thomas Wayne
became Batman and Martha Wayne became
the Joker all these crazy scenario
started unfolding and so ok Barry Allen
says well we have to prevent this
universe from happening so we're going
to go back into the past again and I'm
gonna let my mom die that happens and
then the new 52 universe was born let's
say that in that example in that
timeline that dr. Manhattan stepped in
and let's say that when he did step in
that where the actions of Barry Allen
should have led to the universe going
back to the way it was before before the
new 52
dr. Manhattan stepped in and screwed
with things and that resulted in the
formation of the new 52 universe he said
well you know what instead of things
going back to the way they're supposed
to be let's take Superman and let's
split them in half
let's make him two totally separate
people and let's just see how that plays
out that would fit in with the idea of
the pre new 52 Superman and the premium
50 C Lois Lane and their son Jonathan
Kent just being there one day and then
the new 52 Superman's just running
around doing his own thing that would
make sense
it's entirely possible that that's the
case but the fact that that's possible
means that almost anything is possible
so it's kind of crazy in terms of how it
all plays out but I really hope you guys
are getting kind of amped up about this
idea of the Watchmen because we got to
think there's a guy out there presumably
dr. Manhattan with the power to
manipulate the entirety of universes and
that really begs the question if it's
true what can the Justice League do to
stop him what can anybody in the DC
Universe do to stop him because I would
say if that's the kind of power he
possesses and the most powerful being we
had ever seen in the DC Universe was mr.
Mixel pedelec and mr. mitchell pedelec
was power
was in the face of dr. Manhattan then
there's never been an instance when any
villain in the Justice League has ever
emerged or any villain in DC Comics has
ever emerged with power on this scale
no one's ever appeared with that kind of
an ability before say for maybe the
presence who's like the God in the DC
Universe and he's appeared something
like 20 times so again it creates kind
of a wild scenario in terms of how
things can unfold but in any event if
you guys do feel yourselves a little bit
lost if you guys do you feel yourselves
a little bit confused feel free to post
your comments down in the comment
section I'll answer them as best I can
also make sure you check the Superman
playlist so that you can get caught up
on everything that's going on and not a
probably answer a lot of the questions
you guys have but if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]